there's only one shot that I could tell
was a VFX shot when I actually saw the
movie oh whoa yo what's up Gavin hey
guys welcome back to another episode of
VFX artists react today we are joined by
Sam hi Sam hey what's up guys the film
industry is dying because of covin 19 so
better suck up these clips here because
this is the last good movie you ever
seen hey guess what we've got some great
clips for you all today let's kick
things up that bullet singing an impact
is cloth I love I love the lighting from
the ground illuminating them as they run
by so I don't know like what internally
within the movie justifies slow-motion
but it was super sweet this is the big
brain yeah they're trying to show off
fast he's thinking Oh gotcha right you
know we're taking for granted here how
fast the camera is moving or like if
they have movement and slow motion means
the camera had to be moving ten times at
speed to actually get it to look like
it's moving yeah motion it allows them
to actually capture all of those crazy
particles in the air all the debris and
whatnot I know some of that is is
probably digital but I don't know how
much of it is I would imagine that the
cameras are definitely moving fast
enough where you can't have a human
operator well I don't know
can you human operate this you know
Gavin actually worked on this movie
right you mean Gavin of the slow-mo
ghost named Gavin from the guillotine
Channel me Gavin from the guillotine
Channel
every single one yes I wear if you'd be
down to chat about this real quick hey
why not yeah I'm gonna call Gavin yo
what's up Gavin no we're taking a look
at this shot from Sherlock Holmes - how
did you guys film this it was real
forest in the UK and they set up I
figured speed rail it was like over a
hundred meters of track and I think at
top speed the camera could mean around
10 meters and we had two phantoms on
electronically-controlled heads and with
different lenses in the movie they
actually punch in from the wise to the
tight and I guess it makes sense so they
basically did the 300 thing where you
have multiple cameras at different focal
lengths and then they're just stitching
them together for zooming in and out so
my question is was there an operator on
these cameras or were they unmanned and
programmed it was like just like Aussie
controllers that dick no pain
controlling the heads so like I would
set all the settings on the camera and
I'd unplug it and it would slide all the
way back down to the beginning of the
shot and then it would sort of speed
back so it's just and I don't my god
plug in at the end and download the
shots so they had like actual charges on
the real trees in the woods which were
going off and they have real stuff in
the floor and then what we did we set up
the exact same track again against a
massive green screen and that's where
they did all the casters of like the
trees that I like split open and like
coming hearts and stuff that was like
some fake trees on green screen and
another fun fact about that shot there's
a scene where a guy picks up a rifle and
shoots a bullet in it so it goes through
the vest of Jude Law yeah that was a
real bullet fired a dummy wearing the
same outfit at firing range
yeah we match the frame rate and
everything so that bad that bullet
travel is like accurate to what it would
have been like if he was midair and that
is like the correct speed of the bullet
was that's medication to realism right
there yeah I think it's a crazy secret
hey thanks a lot for chatting with us
dude I appreciate it yeah thanks sir I
didn't really appreciate it I didn't
realize how much actually went into like
doing all this stuff it looks insane
and you just kind of assumed oh they
just shot it on a slow-mo camera but
there's so much work in preparation and
post effects that go into making this a
full package thanks again to Gavin for
chatting with us you can check out his
very popular channel the slow mo guys
link in the description so we're
watching this clip because you guys left
lots of comments saying check this out
break it down if you have a movie we
should take a look at leave it in the
comments below
oh no manners what a country bumpkin
congratulate have the field be in all
America alright there's real JFK how did
they do that how do they have Tom Hanks
shake hands with JFK we're gonna break
down the scene and try to figure it out
we're gonna be VFX detectives here we're
gonna solve the mystery of how did they
do this okay they just took static like
a tripod footage of JFK speaking cut out
the head body double copy/paste I think
I can see the elements JFK is cut out
from some old newsreel right it's the
whole body because I noticed the frame
shutter on the on the face but when you
go frame by frame you can see it on the
whole body the tie everything so what
they're doing is basically taking old
footage that's at a different frame rate
and reinterpreting it to match the movie
the background in the dudes standing
around that's all modern that was all
shot by Robert Zemeckis or the second
unit director so everything we're seeing
here except for JFK was captured
specifically for Forrest Gump
yep Tom Hanks here is probably shot on a
green screen and tried to shake his hand
with where JFK was and the shadows are
just hand cut out shapes that move
across JFK how do you interact with old
footage of JFK JFK starts shaking his
hand before Tom Hanks because his hand
in it oh yeah look at that
he's like yeah they just slip into each
other it's like hi you know everyone
does that yep they probably do bust out
rulers and see Stan's employed a tennis
ball in the right spot for Tom Hanks
shakes it and maybe there's some ease
even there with like a metronome you're
like alright three two one step shake
shake shake and like and you know like
he's getting the rhythm and going
through and then somebody steals to go
in and like manipulate his hand to put
it in just the right spot to match JFK's
I just noticed a little fun a fun treat
can I give you gonna get you guys a fun
side street yeah
ready the color of his tide changes
those are two different shots so the
handshake is one and then he turns and
that's a that's a new piece of footage
oh dude Sam you are you just got
promoted from detective to captain this
is a very pretty movie I love the way
this was shot like all the sets and like
the house or it looks super super cool
they look super clean it's a very
pleasing movie to look at the thing
about this movie is that no one ever
expects there to be any visual effects
in this movie and yet I think something
like half of the shots for actual VFX
shots and I could why when I first
watched the movie I was like there
there's no visual effects in this film
exactly because they're so flawless and
also invisible most of the effects in
this movie are simply like set
extensions because they actually built
the real set in small localized chunks
the entire house ever in room is
actually a different sound stage you
know in a warehouse it's not an actual
house so anytime we're seeing the house
from the outside they had to render that
wow they're in like a ditch you can kill
again we hope you like it the car
driving looks really good yeah hard to
make car driving look good on a green
screen or blue screen do you think
they're even pulling a key on the stuff
they're probably rolling it all by hand
hey do you want to know a dirty secret
about doing visual effects just because
you have a blue screen doesn't mean
you're not gonna be doing some
rotoscoping because chances are you're
still gonna have to do some rotoscoping
even if there's a blue or green screen
behind you blue screens help define a
good edge so even if you do have to go
through and rotoscope at least you have
a really good idea of where the edge of
that person is but honestly it requires
kind of the same amount of work as if
you didn't have a blue screen at all I
mean for the whole Avengers thing they
filmed it all on this set that was
supposed to be like in the woods and
it's all burned down and they replaced
everything and I meant manually
rotoscoping every single
character from every single shot that
they actually filmed all of the sets not
used
so another thing that they did in this
movie is they actually built a real set
that was specifically designed to
contain water like a giant pool and they
filled the entire set with water there's
this whole scene where like the entire
street is flooded and the house is all
flooded the those lights off in the
distance there yeah that's a set
replacement they're the rotoscope
artists are the real heroes here oh yeah
in the motion-tracking guys like you get
you get a good rotoscope team and a good
motion-tracking team at that point you
can just grab some pictures and thrill
men it'll look good there's only one
shot that I could tell was a VFX shot
when I actually saw the movie and that's
when there's a reporter outside of the
house talking mmm yeah Alex lead you
there so the thing that gave it away for
me and I don't know why but it has
something to do with the really wide
angle linear perspective of a lens it's
got that really wide fov that you see in
videogames sometimes it isn't very well
done but for whatever reason that was
the only moment where I was like wait a
minute I think they did a fully CG shot
there basically the moral of the story
for parasites visual effects is that
even if they're maybe not that advanced
the fact that they are so seamless and
no one ever notices them they achieve
the results perfectly of never being
known wait hold on it's that time of the
year it's that time of the year to check
who here is watching this corridor crew
channel and not subscribed all right
let's take a wild gander what is the
percentage of unsubscribed people
watching our episodes Sam 6512 both of
you are wrong it is fifty two point six
percent over half of the people watching
this video right now I not subscribe to
this channel I had a child
earlier this year she's two months old
and the first question she asked me is
why aren't you subscribed
[Music]
relax I Tonya or the story of Tonya
Harding played by Margot Robbie yeah so
Margot Robbie is portraying a
professional Olympic ice skater whereas
she as an actor is not but she's on
screen performing these incredible
ice-skating maneuvers she can go ahead
she can you know ice skate and do a
little dance and stuff that's fine but
this crazy ice skating stuff isn't
definitely beyond her so what they have
to do is they have to replace the face
of an actual ice skater with Margot
Robbie space I can't help this is real
or not
there's probably real still right yes be
real still her hidden cut right there oh
yeah yeah I can see it they're just a
little too clear the clarity was a
little too high
looks right here like this all works
this works really well I don't know
there are moments where I'm like I feel
like the face doesn't have enough motion
blur or something it's just like I can
see that it's Margot Robbie's face not
terrible it's not bad no it's like it is
actually really well done in my opinion
oh yeah I don't know I mean I think this
is an example of a good face replacement
though it's a trick it's right on that
line and like sometimes they go over it
and sometimes they don't like just some
stuff that works great there's some
stuff it's like boy they cut out a face
and put it on her that right there okay
that frame looks funny okay okay I'll
give you guys this job yeah cuz their
facial performance here is very static
it's and maybe that's due to the fact
that they only have three months to do
this entire scene I'm just saying when I
watch this movie the face has never
jumped out at me at all and that's the
thing the only reason why I'm noticing
it is because I'm looking for it well
this movie I didn't pay attention to
that at all thankfully they don't show
you the BTS right before you watch a
film this is the thing where it's like
you watch any video that we've made
people oh I thought that looks pretty
cool and we could be like you're watch
this Marc frame I frame it totally sucks
Oh
this looks great like this totally works
the see the face is moving like you can
see your eyes go from the ground to
looking up you can see a smile happen
the motion blur is dialed in perfectly
the colors are dialed in really well the
lighting is not really changing too much
but there's so much blur that's hiding
that okay they just shifted right there
and now the face is so dead again
it's so flat alright so we pulled up a
video of the actual VFX breakdown for
this scene so I'm really actually
curious to see how they approach this
shot so what we did was we set up a
small studio on location to scan Margot
Robbie's face and give us the overall
head model with textures expressions
answered it right there
CG face done what a mole I want to see
that version of this movie like just the
floating head they said they use two
different techniques I bet there's par
sports just her cutout face probably and
those are the parts that actually in my
opinion don't look as solid if I was
going to try to improve this in any way
I would have just tried to like bring a
little more life into the eyes and they
had the eyes be a little more alive I
think they would have sold me I think
they would have tricked me the
background crowd looks great by the way
that like that doesn't even register we
never actually think about the fact that
there are thousands of people in the
stadium that aren't actually there
[Music]
head on over to corridor digital dot
store to go ahead and pick up your own
hat sweatshirt any burden see green
screen blanket or other great items we
have there such as a corridor now Gina
did you just say we have corridor genes
corridor now genes oh when you guys are
facing away from me it's really hard to
understand what you're saying corridor
digital that store quarter digital that
store if you guys enjoyed watching this
video don't forget to subscribe also we
have a lot of other YouTube channels
these days corridor caps the podcast
where we got to speak our true feelings
you're gonna go back in time
can you met Hitler as a baby I'm sorry
it's really cool I highly recommend it
it's available on podcast sites
everywhere and the quarter past the
YouTube channel we also have node where
we use our brain powers to come up with
some of the coolest creative game types
both in video games and in live-action
something you can even play at home too
thanks everyone for watching see in the
next episode